i don't need all the answers
but we do harry at least when it comes
to your relationship with
olivia wilde e.t is learning more about
the potential new couple as olivia
reunites with her ex
jason sudeikis romance rumors first
sparked over the weekend when the 26
year old singer and 36 year old actress
director were spotted in santa barbara
holding hands at a wedding e.t has
learned that the pair attended nuptials
for harry's manager
jeff azoff and get this harry even
officiated the ceremony
i enjoyed the experience a lot as for
how olivia and harry first
linked up well they're currently working
together olivia is directing harry and
don't worry darling a psychological
thriller centered around an
unhappy housewife in the 1950s a source
tells et that they're together for long
days on set
and have gotten to know each other
really well so it's all
very organic the source adds that olivia
wouldn't let a romantic relationship get
in the way of a professional one
quote anything they're doing is being
done thoughtfully
a second source also opened up to e.t
explaining that the book smart director
has been more open to seeing new people
since splitting from her ex jason
sudeikis last year
quote she's always liked harry and it
was one of the reasons she cast him and
since then she's developed a thing for
him but for now we can be fun
as for jason olivia's former fiance of
nine years
the source insists they still talk all
the time
and are close because of their two kids
six-year-old son otis and four-year-old
daughter daisy
quote it's highly unlikely he was
blindsided by this news
in fact after olivia attended the
wedding with harry
she was photographed with jason outside
his house in l.a
that's olivia in purple chatting with
jason casually up
against a fence back in november a
source confirmed to et that olivia and
jason were going their separate ways
after nine years together
i'm just every day more grateful and
realizing how i've completely won the
life lottery and it's just so clear to
me at every stage of his
growth and my own growth as a mother so
it just makes me realize how lucky i am
the source explained there was no drama
they just didn't work out as a couple
but continue to be each other's biggest
supporters
which was exactly the case when et spoke
with jason in november
the day before news of their split broke
olivia
her production of don't worry darling
got shut down for a little bit because
of some positive tests so
how is she doing with all this because i
know she was really loving directing
this
oh she loves it and she's great at it
and it's like a um
yeah it's not easy it's amazing the to
see her resilience
and and and she just you know she's just
works her butt off
they're i think a week into their 14-day
hiatus and they got they still had
another week
but you know she's editing the stuff
they already shot you know she's using
her time
you know and she has so many other
projects in the in the works that she
you know
she's she's kicks ass that way
you